One of the things that's quite
interesting about people who have Russo,
he and ideas about children,
so children are all good and they get
corrupted by society,
which is half true because they're also
not good and they get shaped and
discipline by society.
But there were so many types after our
very interesting.
When their kids hit teenage years or
when they're judging like say criminal
teenagers.
It's like the child is perfect until
they hit like 11.
Then they turned into a teenager and
then they're like thugs.
So they go from good to thug in one
move,
you know?
And,
and you often see that in families too
that have treated especially their
daughters like a princess,
you know?
And then they hit puberty and the
parents who have princess them to death
have no idea what to do with them.
And so then they become demonized.
And so the,
the overly good child turns into the
overly wicked teenager.
And sometimes they'll act that out to.
One of the things I've seen with girls
who are held in princess esteem when
they're little and their parents have
too tight a grip on them.
And too much of a demand for good
behaviors,
they'll find some nasty character to
associate with who will tear them out of
the family.
No bikers are really good for that sort
of thing.
So not.
And especially if you have some vengeful
thoughts towards your parents.
Nice.
Biker is your perfect solution to that
problem.